So far, the matrix class hasn't done all that much for us. I've shown you how to
do exactly what you already knew how to do, translate and rotate around the x, y
or z-axis. Here's a transform that isn't built in to the object 3D class, axis
angle rotation. And for that, you really do need to use a separate matrix. Say I
want to make a little star shaped ornament out of four cylinders. Or if you're
feeling more dramatic, I want to make some carbon fiber caltrops to trip up the
robo-minotaurs about to launch a final assault on our base on[UNKNOWN] Prime,
it's really our only last hope. I'm better now. Well anyway, I want to align the
four cylinders with the four diagonals of a cube. The hard part is figuring out
the rotation matrix I want to use. If I'm stuck using Euler angles, do I rotate
in y, and then in x, or z and then in y, or something else? With the axis/angle
function, I need to figure out what axis I want to rotate around, and how much
to rotate. We're going to use cylinders to make our object. Here's a cut-away
view of the cube, showing the original position of the cylinder and its desired
location in the wire frame along one of the diagonals. Every cylinder starts
pointing up along y-axis. Step one is to figure out around which axis to rotate
this vertical cylinder. I want to rotate the cylinder to the point x y z all
equal to 1. The question to you is which axis do I want to rotate around in
order to get this cylinder into its final position? Your choices are axis one,
which is along the y-axis, axis two, which goes along negative x and z, axis
three, which goes along this xyz-axis itself, and your last choice is axis four,
which goes along the z-axis. Mark each that is correct, if any. If you get
stuck, you might want to go back to the answer for how we formed a disc-shaped
object out of the swept clock hands, as that might help you out.